although hello may I speak to Sir John
Gurdon please uh yeah this is stronger
than speaking oh hello my name is Adam
Smith I'm calling from the Nobel Prize
website in Stockholm oh yeah we have a
tradition of recording extremely short
interviews with new laureates would you
mind talking to for just a very few
minutes no that's finally can I just see
a thing can you can you hear me now I
can hear you beautiful yes okay yes i
can know if we got a new phone and it's
a little bit erratic but i can hear you
now i feel if we're speaking to me could
speak in this way yes I shall I shall I
shall transfer to be really thank you
very much well I think thank you and of
course first our sincere congratulations
on the award well I'm immensely grateful
of course what more can one say may I
may I ask what you were doing when the
call from Stockholm came yes I was in my
early i get into lab early and leave a
bit early to so i like to have an hour
or two before everyone comes in so I was
in my in my lab doing things getting
dealing with the usual sort of emails
before you get down to lab work which I
still do and do you recall your initial
reaction to the news well yes it goes
the first one is it's amazing if it's
really true could it be someone's
pulling your leg and that has happened
before you know people somehow the date
when the announcement is made and decide
to tell you that that news it isn't
totally incorrect so you have to be a
little bit cautious in believing that
the person you're speaking to is
actually has a right husband but he sort
of said he was secretary of the
foundation and mentioned things that
made me think it probably was real but
of course your initial reaction must
always be is it just a someone teasing
you mm-hmm I
I I imagine the Swedish accent helps
make it sank yes thought that helps too
but you have to be a bit cautious I
think quite it has been it is indeed the
50th anniversary of that 1962
publication of yours so it has been a
long time yes well it's perfectly true
that the the major publication of which
no doubt the award was made was actually
it was 50 years ago and the experiment
was course done a bit before that so
it's I'm fortunate of course to survive
long enough to have this amazing honor I
suppose it says something about the
progress of science and expand how
expectations shouldn't be too great that
things are going to yield benefit
immediately I think that's right yes and
of course one is always looking for
therapeutic benefits and I would say
when the work was done there was over
virtually no expectation of any
immediate therapeutic benefits so the
recognition as it were as the early
result one can understand has to wait
and indeed there was quite a period
after the early work when people were to
not believe the results so it took about
nearly 10 years for the major result to
be accepted well quite because it was 50
years ago and you were just a graduate
student at that point I was indeed a
graduate student yes when the major
result was obtained that's absolutely
right that was in 1958 and then I took a
postdoc job in California working in a
completely unrelated field so i left my
frogs which i'd grown with my supervisor
who'd moved to geneva and he and the
technician grew them up so that by 1962
they were adults and one could publish a
paper to say that these these animals
derived from nuclear transfer really
were absolutely normal so it took a
little time to go through in that now
one looks at it is an established fact
but at the time it must it must have
been quite difficult flying in the face
of established opinion and major figures
in the field it was and the the people
who pioneered the technique of nuclear
transfer were called Briggs and King and
they
had developed the technique and they
found before I started work that they
got the opposite result to me in other
words they found that when they tried to
you know the field transplant nuclei
from specialized cells it was not
successful so the conclusion drawn was
actually opposite to what it was
indicated by the results that I was
getting so it's entirely reasonable for
the skeptics to say well these will
establish people have already done this
experiment and has a graduate student
from Europe who's disagreeing with them
why should we pay attention to that but
this was not Briggs himself was a
wonderful person is sadly no longer
alive but he was extremely generous and
and everywhere reasonable so it was just
the skeptics who felt the results must
be wrong so one had to go through a few
years of in a sense letting the results
sinking and people decide if they really
were correct that is how such it works
nothing's working um and certain 1962
also happens to be the year that shinya
yamanaka was born he says he told me
that's not funny yes yes that's rather
than anything isn't it too extraordinary
coincidence yes and and he actually I
was just speaking to him and he was
saying repeatedly how important it was
to him that the two of you are tied and
that his work in indeed builds on yours
and it was only it's only because of
your work that he was able to do his
work so he was expressing his very great
pleasure that the two of you are the
recipients of this year's Nobel Prize
well it's extremely generous of him to
take that view and of course the actual
key experiment he did had nothing to do
with new tip from Sir at all so I think
it's very generous of him to give credit
for the very much earlier preceding work
I'm always he's very generous that way
and always very polite and supportive so
I'm of course extremely grateful to him
for taking that positive view but in his
work he was I think looking for factors
that could turn cells back that was
based on the principle of gene
conservation in differentiation that you
had established so I suppose there I
think that's correct the from the early
point that that all almost all cells of
the body have the same genes i think it
was reasonably clear that given time it
should be possible to achieve a complete
reversal though you know it things take
time to do but once the principle is
there the cells of the same gene smart
my own personal belief is that we will
in the end understand everything about
how cells actually work and so if the
genes are there it seems to me it must
in principle it apostle it must have
been in principle possible to achieve
the functional reversal and but it
depended on a lot on all the technical
advances that have occurred in the
meantime to make these things possible
so some might find that a remarkable
assertion that we will understand
everything about how cells work yes that
is rather rather a resumption it i'll
tell you why i like to think that and i
would should say that i think this I
cannot immediately see the route by
which we should really understand memory
and the workings of the brain but if we
take the earlier stage that is how you
get from an egg to an adult functional
animal forgetting for the moment the
brain I would have thought it would be I
would have guessed in the next 20 years
or so we really would understand in
detail how that works in other words
we'd identify all the molecules in an
egg how they interact with others their
concentration and location I can't see
that not becoming evident and if that is
evidence I would have thought that would
explain how you go from an egg to an
adult animal that I can't imagine for
the moment how one can expect to fully
understand the
things like memory and an aspect of the
brain so I'm really my this rather
presumptuous expectation is based on
really morphology you know the the
functional adult rather than how its
brain might work but it does underline
that all this work is fundamentally
about understanding application is
lovely but understanding comes before
application I think that's exactly right
i would agree with that view that and of
course it very much relates to the
questioners or was being asked which is
should basic science be supported if
there isn't an immediate benefit so
health and of course I'm biased but I
would always hope that the basic science
would be supported because so often it
happens that the the practical or
therapeutic benefit comes along quite a
long time after the initial discovery
well luckily when you come to Stockholm
in December we have a chance to
interview greater links about all this
thank you very much that I understand
the the dates for that or early December
and I'm not look forward to hearing the
programs at home prepared moments I my
thoughts or rather one of amazement and
not had time to entirely absorb this
amazing event but thank you anyway for
talking to me a bit about it I wish you
the very best for the rest of this what
will turn out to be an extraordinarily
busy day well I'm so it will then thank
you very much indeed for calling okay
congratulations again